>> Hello, YouTube.
I'm Ann Veneman, Executive Director of UNICEF.
It's great to be back with YouTube at Davos
for the second year in a
row.
The topic that's being discussed here at Davos
this year is a focus on
the economic crisis around the world.
And as we look at the economic crisis, it's
very important not to
forget the world's most vulnerable, those
who live on less than a
dollar a day, particularly those women and
children whose lives are at
risk, who may not have enough nutrition, food,
may not have access to
essential medicines or the opportunity for
education.
And so as we look at our own economic difficulties,
remember that those
who are most vulnerable are likely to be impacted
in the greatest ways
as we suffer from this economic downturn.
Thank you very much.